you crash the set of the Star Wars
Episode seven yes film which JJ Abrams
and so many of those iconic cast members
are shooting and they're shooting it in
London yeah they're shooting it at
Pinewood which is a studio we shot not
all but a fair bit of Potter stuff in
and I know almost the entire crew from
Potter has transferred to Star Wars and
are now kind of getting ready for like
another 10 years sort of somewhere um
and or however long it's gonna be you
know but yeah it was amazing I'm
actually a very recent Star Wars fan I I
actually only watch the films
the original films for the first time
this year well yeah I know that maze X
that was I mean no it was my mind it's
crazy and it I think it's my parents
whenever into it so it never sort of got
passed on and then you know you're a
teenager and everyone's telling you to
watch something so a little what we all
told me to watch um and and then you
know I finally came around from this
year and they are amazing and it's
fascinating to me because originally I
imagine what made them so successful in
popular was because people have never
seen effects like that and things like
that what makes it stand up is how let
the storytelling right now you know it's
it's a pretty movies I'm like a new Star
Wars that which is very weird to be and
I said did you tell she got me I'm sure
that JJ Abrams was there and he was
excited who was there who did you talk
I'm what I met I did I did I had a
conversation with with housing Ford
which was really really cool yeah and it
may have been on the Millennium Falcon
which was also really cool
you were on the mahlet so I think we
know that I think that's that that's why
I feel safe saying that because I feel
is you can't tell us if I can get
nothing right like nothing well and also
because I don't really know anything I
was just going around and all this is
fantastic
well I think that is I think that they
ship yeah exactly I mean it's so cool
and it really is and what was even
cooler about it was and I did admit to
JJ Abrams and Harrison for that I'd only
recently seen them and JJ Abrams looked
at me for a second like I had grown
another head and and Harris but then
Harrison Ford sort of saved me by saying
that he he has I think it was hang one
of his daughters might not have seen
them or something like that which made
me feel a lot better in yeah cuz I was
pretty I I said I said it like a really
jokey I've only seen them recently and
immediately sort of thought that might
have gone wrong
but no it was and the overwhelming
atmosphere of the place it's just so
excited and everyone you know for
Harrison Ford who's been doing these
films for so long to be so excited about
the new ones just know I think he's an
amazing sight he's also just such a
there are very few actors left to have
that kind of presence yeah I mean he's
been in so many iconic movies and he's
you know
effortless for so many years and it's
just a Hilaire you know and he's he
comes on this show all the time and
people just all he has to do is just
raise one eyebrow and people go crazy
yeah you know he's got lately he's got
that power but he that he's there's an
effortless no and that's what was kind
of great about his work in the films as
well as that there's like it's alls
every old hell's breaking loose around
me it's just so casual and that is like
it just seemed to be quite like the man
I met which is even cooler I told this
once before but I was at like a fair
like a County Fair and there were a lot
of kids running around and fun things
and trampolines in Harrison Ford was
there and with his family and I just
walked up to him and there was a bouncy
castle a bunch of kids were in and I
just said hey Harrison get in the bouncy
castle and he looked at me he said I
don't get in bouncy
that's it just made me really happy yeah
it's like and then he took out a whip
and
you